Now, I think another 25 or so got certified, right?
Manjush?
It should be in the ballpark, 80 to 100.
Oh, that's great.
What you want to do there is make sure that
everyone is reflecting on our list.
So maybe you can just create a ticket and send your list.
Sometimes they take many cases for portability.
They take the exams using their personal email,
which is totally fine.
But sometimes we don't know.
If you don't let us know which email that is.
So that typically fixes 80% of the discrepancies.
They just need to go to their partner academy profile
and add that secondary email very easily.
I can show you where that is if you can pull up
your academy right now.
Or you can go and open a ticket here, send your report.
Like these is the people with the emails
and let our team in the back end do the synchronization.
If you can send the emails, the email they use for testing,
that's the one we would need.
And we probably won't have unless you let us know
which one it is.
Sure, I'll do that.
Yeah, and then make sure that your sales teams
is making sure that everything is being registered
so that we know because in many cases,
partners work on opportunities.
And if we don't know, we don't give you credit
because since this is not a resale relationship,
you can be working with Databricks all day long
and we don't know that you're influencing consumption
unless our A's create the use case
and puts it on the system.
So they create a use case on our system
very tactically speaking, tag you to the use case.
So that's how we know, okay, once the partner is done
implementing and this goes live,
we will start giving credit to the partner.
But that use case needs to be created,
gets created by the by the AE, gets moved through all
the stages by the AE all the way until it goes live
when the credit kicks in, right?
And these AEs are for those accounts.
Evan, should you understand who you need to contact?
Yeah.
Okay.
Yes, let me show you really quickly how you see
everyone, everything we're giving you credit for today.
Because all of this you manage control, yes.
You can manage control, visualize everything
from your dashboard, okay?
Two ways in which you can get contacted
with the account team.
One, which is the one we promote.
If you don't know the account team,
register the opportunity.
That once approved should trigger two things.
One, the SDR with the inside sales reviewing your deal.
Once it is approved, they should come back to you
and give you options of times and dates
to meet with the account executive.
That's one of the things that happens when your deal
is approved and one of the intentions of the deal
is getting you connected with the account team
so that you can discuss the causal motion
you want to have with us.
Whether you want this to be highly involved,
not necessarily very involved,
just giving you, I don't know, information, collateral,
you name it, okay?
And then the other thing that it triggers
is that based on that connection,
the AE knows you're working on an opportunity
and create a use case to give you credit
on the partner program, okay?
So I am impersonating you right now,
Himantri, let me go to sharing.
So Vanessa, there were a couple of new changes
that were introduced this year.
So has the PBS been finalized?
Because I cannot access the PBS guide for this year.
Yes, so the PBS guide is here,
partner program network under anything,
it's at the bottom here.
You can download it here now.
Got it.
So I was trying to access it by the dashboard
and it was not just, it was just not popping up.
The dashboard is under more
and the guide, it's under resources,
brick builder, partner network, FW27 FAQ.
Here you go, went to the bottom, yes.
But you're right, it was,
I think it was published a couple of weeks ago only.
So it took us a little, yeah.
I'm covering all of those topics on the PDC office hours,
by the way, to make sure that I am kind of dissecting
all of the changes and all of the metrics and components
so that you can come back to the teams,
rally the troops, strategize,
how you want to progress on the tiering
or augment your partner value score.
So here in the dashboard,
you can see how many points you currently have,
what is your current tier
and the tier you're trending based on the current numbers.
So with 46, we should be in the silver tier still, right?
Why is it trending towards bronze tier?
Is it something that we're talking about?
The table, the table,
probably because there are other requirements as well.
So we need, let me show you.
Let me see the guide really quick.
Yeah, we need to make sure we don't trend down to bronze.
So whatever it is that we are lagging
in terms of maintaining the silver,
I mean, we should try to get to gold, not go down.
Yes, so right now, yes,
in terms of partner values score,
you're above the requirement, right?
We need, additionally, we need five delivery experts,
which is fairly easy to obtain.
It could be anyone who is certified within the company.
It's going to the academy
and take any of the delivery expert badges.
Those are from 15 minutes to two hours,
I think on the academy and the exam is also on the academy.
And then we need four champions.
So you can nominate them via partners at databricks.com.
I would suggest to do it in October, the latest,
so that it allows for some time for processing.
The next round of the motions happen in February.
So we have all the way until January 31st
to have all of the requirements.
What I would suggest is make sure
that you're subscribed to the newsletter
and also that you're looking into the PDC office hours
where we're bringing these topics forward.
I mean, at this point, the champions are 100% required.
And what does champions mean?
Is there any relaxation for the champion requirement
at this point?
Or is it still you need both certifications
associated and professional?
I'm sorry, can you repeat the question again, please?
I don't need to, sorry, you're saying something.
I was just asking, what does champion mean
and what does it require to have four champions?
Yes, so a champion, it is a different profile
than a delivery expert.
A champion, highly technical, is the person who,
you pretty much assigned on your complex projects
because of their expertise.
And these people that had delivered
multiple successful implementations on databricks.
So the process for them is one, getting nominated.
There are basic requirements to get nominated.
You can get them here.
I'll send them over the chat so you can grab the alias.
There you will get the minimum requirements to nominate them.
Once the nomination is accepted,
they will go under some additional enablement requirements,
a panel interview as well with our champions programs team.
So this is kind of our, before the MVP
is our highest recognition.
So champions are very prestigious engineers.
So I would put forward the ones that are really
had more successes under their belt.
So Vanessa, quick question for you.
Has the requirement been a little bit relaxed
since you're looking for four champions?
Previously it was just one champion.
So has this requirement been relaxed a little bit?
Do you still require both the associate
and professional level certification for these champions
or cause for good resources?
It is difficult for them to take time out
of the existing engagements to focus on an exam.
So is that still a hard requirement
or is that a bit of a flexibility with them?
Okay, so let me check on the requirements.
So one, in terms of relaxing the requirement
of four champions from the program level,
that's why I was suggesting join us
on the PDC office hours every month,
read the newsletter because we are considering it.
But I'm not sure if it's going to go through,
but we're considering reducing the amount
amount of champions, but for now the reducing the amount of champion or reducing the certification
required for champions.
Reducing the amount of champions the for the partner program for the actual program so
that someone becomes champion.
Those requirements are set and are not being considered to be more relaxed because there
is certain profile in terms of level of expertise that is required.
And it's the perfect, you know, is the is the profile that we're looking for.
So that those requirements are not looking to be relaxed at this point that that team
is not working on that at all.
It's more on the program side on how many do you actually need?
Let me check here.
Let me see if I have anything here.
If not, I think I know on the partner portal we have it.
Let me check here.
Also side question, if you know we hire new people who are champions, does do we get extra
points for that?
Like since now that person is part of our team.
Would you get that person will be meeting the required the current requirement of the
partner program correct?
Okay, so if we hire new people who are certified and whatever we get credit for that, right?
That is correct.
You need to email us so that our team associates them in the backend to you as the new company
holding the champion.
Yes.
So here are he mentioned.
Did you see how it got here?
Here are the requirements to apply.
And yes, it needs to be a professional person.
Yes.
This is a highly technical program to really recognize highly technical individuals so
an associate.
It makes sense that they require the professional level before applying.
Got it.
Correct.
So just stay in the loop in case that something around champions gets changed, right?
Because it typically affects a hiring decisions.
So just want to make sure that you know you consider that as I mentioned in my stay as
a hard requirement, but we are in discussions of relaxing this so and maybe reducing it.
So just to stay on the loop, join the PDC office hours and read the newsletter.
Vanessa, how does he mention when the PDC office hours are there?
Is there like a meeting invite that you can forward to him or is it on a standard date
every month?
Let me show you two things.
It gets included on the newsletter that goes out every month.
And the second thing is...
How does he sign up for that newsletter?
Are you already getting that newsletter?
I generally get the enablement newsletter.
I don't get the PDC notification.
I have the enablement newsletter that is going out.
And I've signed up for all of the communication preferences.
Let me give you the link to the newsletter.
I have already signed up for it.
I'm not getting it.
I signed up for all of the communication that Databricks sends out every month.
I've just not received this PDC office hours notification.
Oh, the PDC office gets included on the marketing newsletter as one of the things they advertise.
It's not specifically for the PDC.
So the marketing overall newsletter for partners will include things like PDC office hours
or maybe an announcement on a launch or an update on the velocity program or partner-related
information.
So we just have some real estate on that communication, but it's not exclusive to PDC.
The other way...
That is what I've been saying.
I have already signed up for all of the communication that Databricks sends out.
I have just been receiving the enablement notifications.
I have not received any other notifications.
So I don't have information about the PDC, but I know that there is a Tuesday conversation
which is hosted at what, 10.30 IST or 9.30 PM IST for the marketing activities that are
carried out.
I know about the enablement activities that are going on at this point of time, but I
do not know about the PDC activities.
So would it be possible to send me an invite for the PDC as well or to include me from
the back end into your PDC newsletter?
I haven't heard that, so that's interesting.
Maybe the marketing team can review if there is something wrong with your emails.
And here is how you can not miss any of the events that I recommend.
Literally, here is what I do every week.
I create the weekly digest and again, so that we don't go through marketing and there is
a huge orchestration that needs to happen in the back end to send mass emails to the
partner base.
So we're limited in amount of emails we can send.
And I repeat for privacy rules, I cannot email the entire base every week and it will be
very conversant for me.
It's not necessarily, you know, it will be very operational on my side.
So what I do, I can sign up for that because I have not received the PDC notification.
What I do is I keep on checking out the Databricks website and whenever there is a due notification
at popsup, hey, PDC is happening.
I generally go ahead and sign up for that.
So that is how I ignore it.
Yeah, so the only way that we send mass invites to the PDC office hours is through the newsletter
that marketing sends.
So the one that you're not getting.
So I just dropped an email on the chat because I haven't heard about someone signing up and
not getting it.
So please do email them so they can check your profile and see if there is something preventing
them from communicating with Google, which I wouldn't see.
Because that is kind of the email channel that I use to go out because I need to go
through formally through marketing because Databricks needs to have a formal schedule
so we don't send X amount of emails to people.
So I'm not sending direct invites to the partners.
I need to go through the official routes so that they can check the boxes for all privacy
rules and, you know, how many emails are we sending so they're not too many.
I cannot mass email everyone.
But however, what I do every week, I bring what I call the weekly digest to the partners
to the portal.
OK, so in the partner portal, in the landing page, every week, the weekly digest gets updated.
So here you can download it.
The events are there, but all and other things that are really great for you to see.
They're, you know, one slide only, simple to digest.
However, if you only want to see the events, you can continue to scroll down.
And what the team does when I send this is that they send which are the events that I'm calling
out.
OK, so right now, you send my weekly digest yesterday.
So the best day to check this will be maybe Thursdays because the team is in India.
The team would typically pick set up in less than 24 hours.
So Thursdays is when you will see this updated and you will see actually it's already there.
But I added a few more events on my weekly digest from yesterday.
They haven't updated it.
But as I mentioned, Thursdays is the best time to come here and see which events I am
suggesting you not to miss.
And if you want to see kind of the whole content that I bring, you can download the
weekly digest and see it in this format where I have the weekly digest here.
These are the events.
This is the extraction they take and put it on the main page.
And also some recommended content from .com and some recommended enablement, maybe new
launches or just content that I, you know, it's great to have in front of you.
And then this slide is fairly static.
Are just links that, you know, I want partners to have like top of mind.
So Vanessa, there are two things that I wanted to have a major conversation with you about.
One is obviously the housekeeping activities that we need to do to ensure that we stay in
the silver tier and maybe we can progress through the next year of cold year.
So wanted to understand with you, hey, how can we, you know,
the primary objective is how can we grow or how can we create joint opportunities?
And obviously what are the upcoming requirements for, because I heard that a lot of the big
builder requirements are going to come up next year.
So could you just elaborate a little bit about that?
My primary goal is to how can we really close up more opportunities together and how can we
enter into your writing hundreds list?
That is the primary goal that I'm looking at.
Yes. Okay. Awesome. So the rising 100 list, I'll cover it in a second option because I briefly
touched to it. I do have a few more minutes to go over.
Now, a couple of ways in which
we can generate more CoSail opportunities.
I understand for what I remembered,
your main geo is US, correct?
Or Anita, that's where you typically implement.
What is your geo, your focus?
The clients are mostly based in US, yes.
Okay. Yes. As you can imagine,
we have a lot of partners in US.
The way that the CoSail motion had been generated today,
as of today, it's been organic.
A lot of that being driven by the partner
focusing on generating trust with our teams.
By teams, I mean account executives and partner sales managers,
who are the ones that are mainly involved
directly connected to the customers or the sales teams
to generate that CoSail motion going.
Okay. How is it that partners have been doing that today?
Okay. One, when you work with an account executive internally,
you make sure it's a great experience.
You let them know what your expertise is and so on.
So word of mouth will exist.
You actually can ask for introductions to those A's.
That's one thing.
Second, they create solutions,
prepackage solutions that they can easily
position within their customers that can help them open the door,
more of on the pre-sales phase,
like POC-like offers specifically aligned,
mainly aligned, that is specifically because they
offer them, create them across the board.
But the suggestion would be to create them around the key
solutions that we're focusing on this year right now,
especially because it's very new that all of our teams
are even being compensated on.
Genie, Lake Base, AI get way, for example.
So they're really eager to bump up their numbers
and they're really leaning on those partners
that are investing in creating solutions
that can help them accelerate the sales cycle
and break into accounts.
Now, if your target is enterprise and strategic accounts,
that gets...
So I'll tell you a little bit, Vanessa.
So we have, instead of going forward with the entire
market, we have gone forward with very strategic focus
that, hey, we want to focus on a couple of different verticals.
So one is financial services,
where we have delivered great work on data blitz.
That is one thing that we have.
For example, one of the customers,
that's an eminent advisory firm that is a digital-related business.
They have really gone forward with the...
being put responsible for the entire data creation for them
and then the authentic AI implementation.
So that is one such great work we did.
Then another one has been the work that we have been doing
with the big course about the entire...
Again, an authentic platform that we created for them.
The other one has been in the...
So this is one vertical we have improved, is don't?
The other one is healthcare and life sciences.
So these are two key verticals that you want to focus on,
along with digital-native businesses,
because we understand data-based looks at this
from three different verticals, financial services, FSI,
HLS, healthcare and life sciences,
and digital-native businesses.
So these are our core verticals which you want to focus on,
together with data-based in the US.
Financial services, digital...
And?
Healthcare and life sciences.
Okay.
Got it.
So by the way, these are the use cases
that I can see were giving you credit as of today,
historic only I can see two joint customers.
Yeah.
So there should be one more and DCG data
have been contrast problems.
I'm working together with the account executive over there
to how can we...
With Isabel Cannon over there,
how can we ensure that all of the consumption
we are actually driving even reflects on your portal?
As of right now, you're not getting
the entire picture over there.
So I'm already working with Isabel on that.
So I wanted to understand how can we really
accelerate that entire piece?
You want to really go forward all in the data piece.
That has been, hey, what can we really create with data mix?
How can we really go forward and go out
and progress to the TSI?
That is the core thing that we have been handed out.
Because as of right now, we have stabilized the partnership.
Now that we have reached the silver tier,
my primary goal for silver tier was
I wanted to get a PDM assigned to us
so that we can work in a much more dedicated
and a focused manner.
But with the situation that you've just notified to me,
it seems like getting a dedicated PDM
would be very tough as,
but I would still like to get into the top hundreds
and see how we can grow together aggressively.
Yeah.
100%.
So we cover all of those topics via the PDC office hours.
Actually, we have one on co-selling with us,
and it's called Good to Great.
You will find the recording on the PDC landing page.
And then what I also recommend you is to watch the,
win with us for each of the verticals that you mentioned,
where our partner sales managers who are very specialized
join with the go-to-market leads that they define
the go-to-market for solutions by vertical.
Super close to the AEs.
They actually talk about how to co-sell with them,
specifically for the vertical.
So this is a very frequently asked question
and asked from the partners.
So you would imagine that's one of the things
that we have created on a scale version
for all of the partners to learn and do that.
And believe me, it's the same way a RISC-100
will generate this co-sell motion today.
It's just how you actually get the information
that it will be through a video.
Okay.
Instead of, you know, or both things will happen
for a RISC-100, it becomes part of the conversation.
It literally tells you what the recommendations are,
you know, create your solutions.
It talks about the outcomes maps as well
for you to build solutions.
So Brick Builder is one of the ways as well.
Working on creating your specializations before,
let me take one step back so I can kind of wrap up
the recommendation at a high level.
Watch the win with us by the way.
And in terms of the recognition,
join us in the next PDC office hours.
I'll deep dive into the partner values core points,
the recognition, the use cases from the portal.
So that is really clear and how we can actually have visibility
to everything you're doing, which is going to be considered
also when we run the numbers for RISC-100.
So as I mentioned, the amount of use cases as well
is also important.
So it's important that we can see everything.
Okay. So as I was mentioning,
one of the reasons why I brought this up is because,
yes, we have partner sales managers and teams
aligned to the verticals.
However, not all of the, for example,
customers in Finns are part of that team.
Why? Because depending on the size
that we consider they have for us,
we might put them on the emerging bucket,
even they are Finns or healthcare or manufacturing,
meaning that there is kind of this underlying segment
that we call emerging where we put cross vertical customers
based on their size.
Okay. And that partner sales manager is Arian.
So you can see that, and this is actually good news.
The reason I say that is because when you're working
with the emerging group, the emerging segment of customers,
it's a lot easier for you to be in the future
in front of a sales team, right?
They're more flexible.
These accounts have this part,
these account executives typically have the hunter teams
inside them and they have thousands of accounts
they need to target.
They will be really hungry to hear from you
on how you can help them.
They will be open to let's say run events with you, right?
They will be very keen to hearing those offers
that you might create because they're really meaning
the partners to help us lean in.
And these are, let's call them emerging accounts, new accounts.
Okay. When we're talking about a strategic
and named accounts by vertical,
you need to go through the PSM
because as you can imagine,
these are accounts that will have the account executives.
Sometimes they have more than one.
Really on top of what the customer is doing
and various partners are typically there.
So getting there, you need to have a really strong why.
They would want to bring you in, right?
And kind of break into a new account
that is not necessarily yours today.
So there is a little bit, I would say,
I mean, the value prop needs to be very well-defined.
It needs to be a true reason why you want to be there.
So I think it's great that you, for what I can see,
your account teams, your accounts are more on the emerging side.
Okay. Again, I would all, for these,
they are needing something that they can put in front
of the customers.
I'll give you examples.
I have a partner creating $0 Gini offers.
Another one is creating like, you know, small scope,
but it's still POCs for free for the customers
so they can literally try out some apps
on top of their own data.
So they can try it and taste it and see it
and eventually scaling.
And it's kind of the investment on the partners
that they're really getting creative
on how to have our account teams really accelerate
and put something in front of the customer.
can really help them move forward.
So here is you and your creativity and leaning on
those videos for Win With Us.
Digest the outcome maps,
that it's on the portal as well so you can see where we're
seeing the opportunity across all of the use cases as well.
Again, on Win With Us,
you will be hearing about Biberticle,
which maybe use cases we're needing a little bit more of help,
and actually logos where we need help is also there in Win With Us.
That's the general basic idea.
Now, another thing that is on top of that is having brick builders.
The brick builders is the product that you create,
it could be based on a product or it could be a solution by
Biberticle that gets into the brick builder program and we go to market with you.
Huge focus for us.
You have the basic level which is level,
a silver that we need in order to accept brick builder nominations.
We are already a brick builder.
We are brick builder JNI partners.
So my solution is already there in there.
We were in the initial cohort that was accepted in December.
So December 9th,
I believe you onboarded us into the entire brick builder program.
So we are not just the marketing partners,
we are actual defined partners.
I can share the link with you,
but tell us about our solution.
Awesome. I'm assuming it's
on the brick builder page.
It's on the Databricks page.
It's on the Databricks is a big way to reach.
Let me just share the link with you so that you have a time to answer.
Awesome. No, that's great.
We did have some partners with short.
You can see it by the chat.
I've just posted it in the chat window.
You can check it out.
Awesome. Yes.
So the brick builders are also exposed to our sales teams.
Here we're getting to the data-driven way in how we're doing things today.
We're starting to do things today.
Brick builders, yes, they get exposed via this page as of today,
but now we're taking a more data-driven approach.
The thing that I'm saying is,
even if I do create my solution that is very specific
or very that can qualify for a brick builder,
but at the end of the day,
I need to have a joint win together with Databricks
so that I can get that solution put forward for the brick builder industry page.
If my understanding is correct, I need three customers for that.
So how can I close this gap?
If I need to create a brick builder to get a customer
and I cannot get a brick builder until unless I have a customer,
that's like a chicken and egg problem that I'm hitting with.
Well, this is something similar to the Champions.
The intent of the program for a brick builder
is to bring proven solutions
that we can have Databricks behind
and validating and going to market together.
So we do expect to be launched into at least one customer successfully.
It's one of the requirements so that we actually make it part of the program.
Yes. And then the other thing that it's also a requirement to have Databricks,
including it on the brick builder program,
and making that validation is that the partner obtains the underlying specialization.
So for example, for this one, most likely you will need the GNES specialization
so that we know the partner has expertise on the area where, you know,
in which it's creating the offer.
So that's another requirement that it will be needed for a brick builder.
So the suggestion will be to continue to obtain the specializations
positioned in one customer and then submitted for a brick builder, for sure.
I think that being part of the launch gives you visibility,
so ideally, you know, it helps a little bit to get,
because we want to kind of accelerate to get those parts during customers.
But I would put some effort, like go to marketing,
go to market effort behind the solution
so that you can get it going and implemented.
OK, so just to wrap it up,
brick builders, we're launching a sales AI tool
to really even the field, right?
All of the co-sell motion and efforts that I have covered
are more on the word of mouth, whether someone knows me, they don't know me.
So what we're doing right now is we're launching the sales AI tool,
which will be leaving inside of CRM,
and it will be recommending the best partner to the AEs
based on the use case they're working on, what type of use case it is,
what vertical it is, what type of solution it's needed, right?
And in the back end, it's going to be based on data
suggesting what the best partners to work with that use case are.
They're going to be considering things such as whether you have the specialization.
It will be considering the tier as well.
It will be considering the amount of similar use cases
that you have delivered, for example.
So it will be more data-driven.
So whether you have worked with the account in the past as well.
So it's going to be more data-driven.
I would totally recommend leveraging that
and continue leaning on the formal programs
so that you can start more and more showing up
as the recommendation, the partner recommended for the use cases.
I can also set you up.
Another way is we do this for the rising 100s,
but I think it might be something that you can take benefit on
is giving you, connecting you to our crossbeam account.
Have you used crossbeam in the past or know what can crossbeam do?
Okay. So it's kind of we authorize you to see
who is the accounting for our overlapping accounts.
So we'll look into your CRM and our CRM
and the accounts that overlap that match.
It will give you visibility into who the account executive is.
Got it.
So you use some proactive engagement there,
meaningful proactive engagement, right?
And say, you name it, with the intent,
and especially as I mentioned, you will also see
what type of account it is, right?
If it's a strategic prospect or key account, right?
So if it is a prospect, I'm pretty sure our A will be
very happy to hear that you have your account
and that you have all the interest to start working,
especially if you have an idea on where can you start
and how you can start.
And again, if on top of that you have an offer that you want
to use to start the engagement even better,
pretty sure it will be all ears.
And that type of effort that partners do,
I really getting spotlight very quickly.
Like when you come up with an offer that they can position
and replicate and help more on the pre-sale side,
that is getting a lot of traction,
especially for the new products.
If you come up with anything like that,
happy to hear what that is, should we an email?
What type of offers do you mean, Vanessa?
Yeah, so for example, you come up with an offer
that an A can take to the customer and say,
hey, the partner will do some sort of work for you
to try a Gini in this certain amount of data.
Of course, you put the guardrails,
you're not going to do a full deployment,
you actually set aside a few hours of engineering.
And so you set up the guardrails, but it's kind of try it.
Probably they will keep it most likely with the guardrails
of the POC.
But it's something that the A can really take.
And besides not necessarily focusing on the slide deck,
just the selling pitch, but more on just the POC.
Yeah, yes, it's a working POC.
Okay, yeah.
Sure, yeah.
We are talking to a couple of account executives
regarding the same as well.
So I think we can definitely work that out.
Yes, and actually you can do this.
You can actually ask the AEs to maybe connect you
if you're willing to open that up
in a way that it can be replicated.
You can say, you know, the spin great success blah, blah, blah,
and just ask to be introduced to their manager
and ask some space on their team meeting.
And just to start there, right?
And say, okay, and you can actually talk about the capacity,
how many of those you can make.
You know, and so ideally, say, get the prospecting
to this stage that we invest, I don't know, our resources well,
you want to have good leads, right?
So just structure all that.
They can actually give you access to their own teams as well,
specifically, especially if, you know, at any level, right?
But when you're working with emerging accounts,
they're, as I said, they're really hungry for partners to lean in.
Actually also offer to a sponsor QVRs for them, for their teams,
offer to run events with the customers.
Like it could be.
virtual or it could be in person.
Yeah.
Um, you can do that.
I know that a lot of the hunter teams are being tasked with
launching certain amount of events a month.
Yeah.
And they've started to have a huge budget.
So a lot of them are wanting partners to split in.
I have seen half and half and that the investment is not too high.
The acquisition of the audience sometimes is the partner putting one resource
to call out, but the, the Intel sometimes can be mixed coming from the
AE and coming from you.
For example, I have seen that happening as well.
So if you're focusing on that segment, they're really hungry to co-sell with you.
Um, yeah.
So if you want some, you know, I would definitely start with the AEs ask for,
you know, when you have like the value prop, what are you going to tell them?
Ask to be connected with their lead.
If not, you know, just with cross beam, you can see who they report into.
So would you like me to set you up with cross beam?
Yeah, that would be awesome.
Me.
Request for that access.
Yeah.
We don't know about how resources are available to us.
So this is really helpful.
Awesome.
I'm happy to hear.
Let me set you up.
This should give you more visibility on our teams and allow that
co-sell motion to speed up a little bit.
Sometimes, um, he, uh, Giovanni waits for a good amount of requests on my side.
To accumulate, and then he sits down and connects everyone.
Uh, might take a few days.
Okay.
Or you could.
I had one more question.
For example, you know, if I'm looking at, you know, a potential pick any name like
CVS or Walmart, how do I know who is the account executive from Databricks for that,
uh, that company?
Yeah.
So again, if, if you have the account created on your CRM, it will display the
account executive name for you because what cross beam does is that it, it, it
searches on your CRM and our CRM overlapping accounts gives you the account
executive information.
Himanshu, do you know how to do that?
I would have to check up.
I am not aware of that.
Mm hmm.
There is a, I think there is a quick video or getting a started guidance that you
get once we set you up with cross beam.
So you can see how to interact, but I have seen the interface is fairly simple.
It's literally the, the accounts that we have together.
You can see a column with the name of the AE and so on.
Those types of accounts for Gita are the ones that, um, if you don't have our
relationship with the account and you want to be introduced, those accounts are,
you know, one of the, you know, big accounts for us.
So they have established relationships and so on.
So we will need to have like a strong value prop on and go through the partner
sales manager to get introduced to the AE.
Like when it comes to key accounts or named accounts, strategic accounts, um,
it's a little bit, you know, of course, nothing prevents you from introducing
yourself to the AE.
The recommendation would be have a strong value add, right?
And avoid, and here is a recommendation, right?
For what I have seen, avoid, um, the, the, the, the capacity and capability
pitch focus more on the true value add, like literally related to the account.
So that we step aside, especially in the U S market, where we have so many
partners and many, you know, doing this type of approach so that your email does
not sound generic.
Yes.
Talk about capacity and capability, but that's not the whole thing, right?
It should be just a portion of it.
Just focus on the true value add that you're bringing that makes, makes it
special and, you know, they can set you aside from potentially other introductions
that they get.
Yeah.
No, I was thinking from this perspective, like, you know, I, uh, have several
of my batch mates from IT Daily Time or, you know, from Georgia Tech or my
Columbia, uh, you know, experience who are at, you know, senior leadership
positions at several, you know, U S companies.
So if I think that, you know, I can, um, get a introductory meeting with them or
their team because they are all at, you know, um, you know, leadership roles,
which are dealing with data.
Reven decisions, et cetera.
And if there is a way for us to team up with the Databricks team and then
approach them with kind of, you know, my connections, what is the best way to do
that?
So that will be me.
That will be something valuable.
For example, that your email literally speaks to your connection with the account.
Yeah.
Right.
And we've said more like, Hey, I want to focus on the account.
I think I can, you know, get the door open to talk about so and so in this
segment or this organization, specific organization.
So that should be something they would consider, right?
You know, and you calling out that name, of course, as I mentioned, you talk about
who you are, the trust piece, but I think it's just a minor piece of it.
They will be focused more on what you can bring to the table and your connections.
Of course.
Yes.
That would be something that can get their attention.
I'm pretty sure they both AES and PSMs, they get a lot of emails saying, Hey,
we're great here and we're done this for other customers.
And, you know, how can we, how can I help you?
And, you know, and that those, those, of course, we appreciate all of the partners.
However, for strategic and big accounts, reality is, you know, with so many
partners and most of them being in the U.S., that becomes at some point like
where we have a great ecosystem that can do pretty much everything.
And we, that's the reality.
So what it's really driving traction on those accounts, it's more, OK, what makes
you special for this customer specifically, right?
And that those things, again, can totally, you know,
differentiate your introduction versus the ones that you can put.
So we can put some names there in that portal, see who the account executive is
and try to kind of.
Build a relationship and see if we can pitch together.
OK, that that is one kind of question.
Yes.
And at the same time, you continue to invest, right?
Record those opportunities so that they feed sales AI.
Join me on the PDC office hour, Himantji, so that you can see how, you know,
just recommendations, sounds like you have already done a lot and understand
a lot of how we do things.
You might learn a few things on the next one, just to make sure we're always
have this ability into all of the influence you have.
And we can truly see your capacity, capability, the influence you're having
with the with our joint customers as well.
Sure.
This is very helpful, Vanessa.
You know, we'll be in touch.
We really appreciate your guidance here.
Sure. Of course.
Thank you so much.
And looking forward to see all of that you will continue to accomplish.
Thank you. Take care.
You know, get into your underlist this year and.
Exactly.
Getting the.
We'll be happy to see you there.
Thank you. Take care.
Thank you, Vanessa.